une journée historique pour coignières
ce dimanche 13 septembre le club local
qui évolue en d2 de district recevait
viry-châtillon pensionnaire de ra au
deuxième tour de la coupe de france
une première pour la structure les
quatre divisions d'écart se font
ressentir rapidement les essonniens
marque à trois reprises le score à la
pause 3-0 première mi temps on a réussi
à peu près à tenir et on était mené au
score à 3-0 à la mi-temps sur trois
coups de pied arrêtés les buts qu'on y
ont été marqués c'était donc sur des
coups de coeur était pas sur du jeu en
deuxième période les joueurs de
coignières n'y arrive plus physiquement
les locaux se font surprendre à six
reprises ont plusieurs buts en fin de
match
ils sortent de cette coupe de france sur
le score de 9 à 0 on aurait préféré
gagner évidemment à
la réalité c'est qu'on a eu à faire à
une équipe qui était beaucoup plus
costaud que nous aujourd'hui et qui a
gagné de manière logique en tant que
supporters et ben oui je suis un peu
déçu évidemment j'aurais aimé qu'ils
gagnent je parlais de hold up tout à
l'heure il y avait peut-être un hold up
possible mais bon l'op
voilà on a bien compris que c'était un
peu à sens unique quand même voilà mes
mais bon ils ont fait bonne figure quand
même ils sont pas découragés il ya eu un
bon esprit
dirait sur le match et ça c'est
important coignières devra se
remobiliser rapidement le club jouera
son premier match de championnat le
dimanche 27 septembre sur le terrain de
l'équipe d'aubergenville